so it's been two months since apple
released their m1 ipad pros
that shocked the world with their
performance in about a month since i
released
my ultra detailed review of the 12.9
inch model
so today i want to give you guys an
update now that these have been out for
two months
what has changed what are our follow-up
findings as well as
talk about were we wrong or was i just
too harsh
with ipad os 15 and the 12.9 inch model
with that i want to talk about why have
i seen these
as low as a hundred and fifty dollars
off
in two months after these things came
out
and was vadim just absolutely right
about his thoughts on these
high-end expensive devices let's get
started
with a 12.9 inch model obviously you
guys see it right here
but by the time this video is posted
this thing is probably going to be gone
or at least up there for sale with
somebody picking it up
because it just doesn't make a lot of
sense
i talked about ipad or west being
limiting and spending so much money on
this device but with that i went through
all of those comments on that video and
there are a ton of them
and i really try to be open-minded with
those of you guys that did not agree
with my review
talking about that this is a
supplementary device even at over 2
grand
to a macbook pro and the way they're
designed you're supposed to have both
and that you want to use them for you
know whatever they're best at and that's
exactly what i've been doing i wanted to
give a chance because there are some
things that i
absolutely love about this thing so
i've been going through and using the
apple pencil where it makes sense i've
been using
photo editing software some video
editing software and just seeing how it
works and then flipping back and forth
with my macbook pro so with this thing
the m1 chip has been doing excellent
with photo editing i love
having the apple pencil for that i've
been going through a bunch of photos
my birthday photos i edited and that
experience has been
fantastic until you start exporting
those and in that case i'm sorry guys
but a macbook air at weigh less
is a way better option i've had a bunch
of crashes exporting those photos they
are larger size
but it's an optimized program and i
ended up going back as you guys could
see
to ipad os 14 on this system
just to make sure everything's stable
and i still had those issues let me tell
you
it is so frustrating when you're
exporting it gets halfway done or three
quarters
and it crashes and all your work is gone
at that point
you don't even want to have an ipad and
the difference is the software
even though i've been i'll talk about a
couple extra things that apple has fixed
with ipados 15
just the way that it's made it's not
like mac os you don't have a photo saved
every time it is finished rendering
so if it crashes sure you miss you know
whatever hasn't been done
this thing everything is saved at the
end and it gets erased
and that point all the benefits of the
touchscreen are not really worth it and
really right now i want a macbook that
has a touchscreen apple i think it is
time
now with that i want to talk about
battery life that applies to both of
these
in my usage and in the time this last
month it has been
really noticeable that when you're
pushing these machines
it definitely uses more power than
before with that m1 chip even though it
is
efficient when you're taking advantage
of that extra performance
it it does drain the battery and you're
not getting better battery life than
previous generations like you are with
the m1 macbook air and the m1 macbook
pro
now when you're gaming like we showed
you guys in the comparison with the
previous ipad pro
and those games don't take full
advantage yet of the extra graphics
performance
you do actually gain some battery life
that is excellent
but with that if you're pushing these do
expect these to have
worse battery life when you're really
pushing it about
five hours not the 10 that is quoted now
thankfully
we made one discovery that we actually
posted at the
end of one video as a bonus but not
everybody makes it to the end and i
haven't seen
anybody else talk about this online but
apple actually
changed the way these work and now
if you are charging through the actual
usb type-c port on the device
app allows 33 watts or slightly higher
than that
to be accepted even though they come
with a 20 watt adapter and that might be
just because of the extra power draw
that these things can have
and that's actually about similar to
what we saw the m1 uh mac mini
use as far as amount of power with the
m1 chip so apple is accounting for that
but if you're plugging into the magic
keyboard itself that is limited to about
20 watts and that can make a significant
difference in
speed or if you're actually using the
device doing heavy tasks
if you're going to be charging while
using it or just kind of you know
keeping it at a similar
level so make sure you're plugging into
the ipad itself
now with that onto ipad os 15
apple has listened so this might be a
benefit of doing a view review that is
pretty harsh
and they have changed the five gig app
limit
so you're no longer limited five gigs
and they
up that so an app can request for more
ram if it can use it and these heavier
programs
definitely can use it so that is a great
thing
thank you apple but unfortunately a lot
of the other things that we talked about
in that review have not been fixed the
external display support
hasn't been fixed and that just doesn't
make sense to me but i don't want to
waste a lot of time on that the last
thing i want to say specifically for the
12.9 inch the reason why it's
still here but it won't be is the fact
that many led display i mean
apple nailed it out of the park a lot of
people have been hesitant
talking about blooming talking about
other issues but guys let me tell you
this is the best display that i have
ever put my eyes on
other than that 6k display and of course
that thing is not portable
sure you see blooming sometimes but man
outside in the sun
and watching movies outdoors in bright
lights and at night especially
is amazing and it makes me want to keep
this
just for that reason the hdr is
fantastic the
speakers are great i'm going to be doing
more camping and
gosh i want to keep this you download
the movies on there it looks great
but i just don't think it could be
justifiable do you really need a screen
that's
too grand with the package just for
watching movies
i don't know i don't think that is worth
it but
that just really makes me wish that when
i'm switching over this one
and using this and i think this is a
real start of the show
overall for the price point you get a
killer machine
i wish this had that mini led display
and
this just makes me wanna for those
people that i haven't bought one yet
it just makes it more worthwhile to wait
it might be a little bit
but to get one with a mini led display
because the updates are
awesome and whenever i use this at night
or when it's darker
i wish it was that model but now
switching over this device
man this is the ultimate ipad just like
what he mentioned and one very
interesting thing that he said i think
not in his review outside of it is he
said that people buy the ipad pro
not to get an ultimate computing device
it could be a laptop replacement
and even though that's not what an ipad
should be in my opinion if you're
spending over two grand
you kind of expect the software to not
limit you like crazy
but they just buy it because they want
the best of the best they want something
that is future proof and this is exactly
what this ipad has been
even with the ipad os 15 with the
updates the note taking features
it just makes me want to use this way
more often because it's very capable
very nice to use now the ipad was 15
updates with multitasking everything
else
as far as ipad os as a tablet device
it is awesome for regular tasks the
battery life is great
that m1 chip can sit power if you don't
need a lot of it and there's really
not much to complain about other than
that display and
with the fact that i've seen this as low
as 700
i mean nothing can touch it nothing can
touch it even for a couple years
so if you score a deal what else can
compete with that
pretty much nothing now why has why have
these dropped so much by i've seen them
as low as 150 off for the larger model
100 off for the this one and
it's just because of the m1 chip not
only did that give apple
the ability to give this a lot more
power but also cost savings and just
like the m1 macbook air
dropping a hundred dollars lower and i
think even once 150 lower
these things the same thing apple can
stuff them with a lot more power
and because they're making m1 chips and
so many of their devices
it just means that they're saving money
and at some points the retailers can
also
drop that savings down to you it makes
it even harder for other
companies to compete so overall that has
been my update we still highly recommend
this one
the 12.9 inch model if you're getting
the cheap one
and you want that display you can
actually make use of it it is a great
device
but for an overall computing device do i
think i was a little bit too harsh
honestly guys after trying to apply what
you guys were saying and using it the
way you guys suggested
i still am having a very hard time
making sense unless money doesn't matter
for you sure in that case
buy all the apple devices and use them
but overall
other than the display i don't think it
really is worth it compared to older
options for much less money buying a
refurbished or you new one if you need
that larger size
so thank you guys for watching the spin
max click that circle above if you guys
want to subscribe and help us reach our
goal of a million subscribers before the
end of the year
check out one of those ultra detailed
reviews right over there
this max i'll see you in the next one